Gramps, don't push yourself too hard.
I get it now.
Your glib remarks weren't just for show.
I've got a little better understanding
of you now.
But tell me one more thing!
I don't sense the fires of hatred
for the gods in your eyes.
Tell me the real reason
why you've come to fight the gods.
Even you are asking me that?
You're all a bunch of idiots.
Hatred?
Revenge?
I don't need any of those.
I have no reason.
When protecting your children,
do you need a reason?
Darling…
That's so like Dad.
That's for sure.
All humanity,
the children of Adam,
silently trembled at their father's words
that were filled with such
tremendous love.
Then, even though no one told them to,
for the first time in history,
all of mankind came together as one
and prayed for one thing…
For their father, Adam's victory!
Mankind, at this moment,
has just come together as one!
This lad really is quite nice.
Brünnhilde, that Adam is so totally cool!
It seems we were all mistaken
about this man called Adam.